you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hello everybody and
welcome to the game spot stage here at
e3 2016 this is the coop stage right
here on the show floor it's day three I
can't believe it's almost over I am Lucy
James and I am joined by an esteemed
panel some incredible guest today so
joining me to talk about altering xiii
is Matthew Patrick of the game theorists
hey glad to be here I'm glad I qualify
as an esteemed panel is here deemed
panelist and my my colleague the man who
sits next to me every day yeah I thought
you meant Matt when you said esteem
don't worry yeah my esteem will spill
over I guess okay great residual esteem
I was just enjoying rocking out to that
intro song that was great ya know like
even filming that was so much fun we
just spent half a day running around the
office because we'd already seen your
bet that you did for it with the hedge
over the hedge clippers if you're like
okay we have to best my heart wow I
ready do I raise the bar to that level
huh so we are here to talk about what an
a3 it's been mm-hmm do you think it was
like on par with last year because last
year was like the III of dreams like
Shenmue 3 final fantasy Sofia what do
you think of this year I would say whoo
that's a good question i think this III
had a slow start quite honestly i think
some of the early conferences there
wasn't a whole lot to talk about there
weren't a lot of big surprises there
weren't even a lot of games that were
announced quite honestly yeah um but
then you had kind of Ubisoft kicking it
off and then Sony just bringing it home
i think exceeding everyone's
expectations lot of surprises a lot of
games that are announced and so had you
asked me you know at the beginning of
day one how this e3 is shaping up i
would have been a little bit more mixed
but having walked the show floor a bunch
this year having seen all the
conferences i am very pleased with this
year does it rise up to last year maybe
not quite so much but i feel like this
is definitely a strong a 3 Dave this is
your first III what's experience been
like well the first first conference is
like it's thought I had a leaky start
like what everyone at leak end
yeah Bravo for the weekend i will pour
that again weekend legalese the pun is
strong I can't I cannot say that I came
up with that but I will popular eyes it
okay I'll use it in everything breaks
that we had really surprised in the
first couple of days because everything
was getting drip fed yellers yeah by all
the leaks I think like the biggest
surprise from xbox was when they
announced their like new console
technology right the games like be kind
of I even stuff like Forza mean news
about just from like tiny little hints
yep and it wasn't really until Sony
turned up for like oh by the way
kojima's here they were like okay that's
something coming out to the the Mad Max
sound track down that incredible like a
lit up walkway but let's talk about some
of the games so we're gonna go real deep
on like two games I've got us all
incredibly excited so let's kick it off
with the first look at zelda game player
so we finally got the title breath of
the wild if either of you guys played it
yeah i think i believe we both have
right yep cuz i have not i've watched I
life sat in on a demo and I've been just
sort of you know give me the give me the
pad give me the path what are you what
are you doing sitting here that the line
is already two harbors long behind us we
already have a video like the Running of
the Nerds of people just going straight
to the right it's literally like the
Running of the Bulls I have never
witnessed the start of III from this
perspective like the exhibitor
perspective as soon as the doors open
it's just a mad dash it's it's dangerous
I know that's why I'm kind of glad weird
you know up on the safety of elevate
know where we're in a safe position and
an eerie top where we can watch everyone
else no mundo no moon no no no one's
having gift already mood doors so much
you like obviously the game theorists
you guys do a bunch of theories a link
about his hook shot about everything
about all the universes whether or not
he's dead or not yeah obably is dead
some point or another I don't even think
Nintendo knows at this point what are
you like what your initial impressions
from breast of the wild so I would say
looking at breath of wild um breath of
the wild that it is it's a fascinating
game it is so truly a Zelda game and yet
at the same time is so completely
removed from what everything we expect a
Zelda game to be right um it's it's
incredible uh it's it goes back to
probably the first
our game in the series I think it's
probably the closest approximation that
we've ever gotten to the very first
selda game where the whole world is open
for years to explore at the very outset
or you straight to the final box yeah
exactly that's that's what they tell me
is that you can go straight to the final
boss and hey good luck to do it you know
if you feel like you can take on the
challenge but that's an option available
to you and you know there's no like
linear of item locking things like that
and so that's pretty exciting like if
zelda truly stands for being an
adventure title that is you know create
you know being a hero riding your horse
for open fields and crafting your own
experience this is that game that being
said over decades of playing zelda
titles i'm so accustomed to get dungeon
get item beat boss go to dungeon too
right yeah and now all of a sudden
you're asking me to manage my body
temperature my food sources cook my food
you know here's a bunch of like special
skills that link as he has a carry limit
now yes it's a lot and so as someone
who's been playing with this franchise
for a long time it might be overwhelming
do I believe that Nintendo has done it
right and you know will guide us along
that path absolutely um but it's
definitely going to be a learning curve
for all Zelda gamers myself included as
we kind of get acquainted to what this
new Hyrule entails I mean what I find
interesting is like the nor'-east saying
anything about the story or anything the
Mon of course but they are showing off a
buttload of system yes like just um as
you mentioned needing to keep warm
cooking your food that doesn't seem oh
yeah enemies can drop weapons mid-fight
and you can scrapple a change in your
your weapons degrade over time Dave I
know that when you played you decided to
mess with some of those systems yeah so
I picked at the first time like I'm not
a massive Zelda gamer like I may be
played a few hours of the n64 titles
when I borrow my friends console so as
soon as I picked it up I was like okay
let's just let's just see what I can
break so they have a system that um you
have a magnet basically I brought up a
treasure chest from above a pond and
placed it in the middle in the middle of
the field and that i found this giant
like metal beam so i carefully placed it
on top of this treasure chest that's
okay this is kind of like a seesaw this
interesting that I stood on one end of
it and then suddenly the people managing
the booth came up to me like what are
you doing yeah I'm just like playing
Yeah right if you are able to do yeah
but on the screen is just me holding a
giant boulder over the other end of this
seesaw with me standing on the other end
yeah and I just drop it and link just
fires across the world and they're like
we have no idea you could do that I'd
like with with with like his his
paraglider so father I could have
survived that fall yeah but this s so
cuz of like all the new physics systems
all these new gameplay elements there's
stuff you can do with the world of Zelda
doug has never been possible not it not
only just in cells a bit many other
games did you did you shield slide yeah
tried to do the whole shield surfing
size of a boy that it would actually
work in the water yeah yeah like skim
board a thought that would be cool yeah
but it's a whole new like hidden
mechanic that everyone during my demo
was like oh my gosh that guy down there
did some like shield surfing how do you
do it how do you do it and everyone was
kind of discovering all these new
mechanics as the gameplay demo was going
on so it's it's a really exciting world
I play around with I mean it's coming up
a wii u + NX but obviously nintendo are
keeping schtum they're actually only
microsoft with the people to talk about
a new hardware what do you think the
main difference is it gonna be they said
it's gonna be like a simultaneous
release it's gonna be the same but
surely if it's more powerful hardware
you'd expect the NX version to be
different somehow well the game what I
played was very pretty yeah there were a
few moments where the framerate kind of
slowed a bit down and some of the
textures in a distance we've had speaks
record if it's still early yeah but at
the same time like it was a gorgeous
weather felt like walk walking through
like a studio ghibli movie yes amazing
him what I what I really was amazed by
is that like i said i'm not a huge
nintendo guy i'm a huge elder guy by
played 45 minutes of Zelda I'm gonna get
an NX online I wondered where you bow
yeah it convinced you that way it looks
amazing and obviously playing on the wii
u and it's only gonna play and look
better right NX one would assume like I
I need more of that game now like I've
become a complete Zelda convert at this
point wow that's great see you and for
me like this is this is Nintendo's
Witcher yeah right and and it's really
really exciting I I need to know more
about the NX though like that was one of
the things that I was missing
this III yeah I think that was something
that a lot of people were hoping would
show up there was a lot of rumors about
will it won't it and then to hear
nothing about it I think the only person
the only way that we know that NX is
officially confirmed as Ubisoft made
mention oh yeah their press conference
just dance is giving up just dance on
the edit but every way they gotta come
with NX just and Zelda yeah and
everyone's like oh my gosh Ubisoft just
confirmed the EDX is an existing system
like that's crazy to me um you know and
and if they are promising simultaneous
release then we need to be hearing about
that system very quickly the thing is I
mean I don't understand like normally
they would make a big show of it at e3 I
don't know if they're gonna they don't
really have much of a presence at
Gamescom unless they're gonna like Tokyo
Game Show has been dwindling the past
few years because games bombs been
completely eclipsing it so will be
interesting to see if like that's when
we hear or if they tend to just do their
own thing and direct and just go yep
like let's have a whole hour Zelda um NX
direct I think that that's actually
what's going to happen because they've
had such success with those Nintendo
directs those live streams that everyone
knows this is where we go to get the
latest information about you know all
the big announcements that Nintendo has
to offer instead of trying to compete in
the crowded space of e3 where everyone
is making a big announced right after
everyone's making a big announcement
every couple minutes there's so much
news coverage they recognize hey here's
our one game here's our one experience
we want to see the idea of what this
game is going to represent what it means
for the franchise and then you know now
that you've gotten acquainted with this
here's the next big thing after Scorpios
been announced after you've gotten
acquainted with Sony vr all that good
stuff so you guys were played it and I'm
interested to see after starfox how they
are integrating the the wii u ocean
could local controls because starfox it
didn't go down this oh well the um I
mean I starfox was the only game i
played it gave head III last year and i
just was holding the wii u gamepad and i
was thinking i have no idea what i'm
doing and this doesn't feel right
doesn't feel natural is it a necessary
component to Zelda or is it just so you
can play with the pro pad to me and and
feel free to hop in but to me I didn't
really get a sense of much motion
control in this game
all like yes you could aim your bow by
using the gyroscopic controls um but
other than that really that was you
could also am using the the control
sticks yeah right so I didn't really get
a sense of how most how motion how touch
would really apply to this maybe there's
a menu screen on the gamepad but other
than that and especially if they're
looking to simultaneously port this to
NX presumably we don't know anything
about if I like presumably that'll have
to be kind of kept to a minimum it just
felt like a like a bit of a bonus I
think the only time I really use the the
motion controls is I I was magnetized
this Boulder and swinging the motion
controls right wing the boulder in two
skeletons which felt fun but like said
it's more of a bonus that like a cool
gameplay level it's just like a nice to
have mmm so it's gay I mean we're all
very much excited about Zelda but
another game I think this is my game of
the show to be honest really it had such
an incredible showing the uso press
conference maybe I think sticker true um
the sequel to stick of truth fractured
but Hall had be the better trailer but I
love the idea of for honor and I loved
what they showed so let's talk a little
bit about this I know Matt you've been
you played even playing a bit i have got
game i love it yeah there's an episode
of game lab about in my new series but
uh but yeah i've gotten a hand I've my
first hands-on experience was last III
the sword combat was incredible you know
it's such a far departure from what you
expect of you know sword fighting in a
video game right so much of sword
fighting in video games is button mash
you know just kind of hack your way
through enemies but here yes you have
kind of your hack your way through the
minions but then you get to those kind
of like hero battles and you do have
that like parrying system you have it's
it's very rock paper scissors in its
execution where you're having to
thoughtfully consider your attacks the
direction what your opponent's doing all
of that even even simple things like
fainting a move one way and then like
swinging around the other way all of
that is possible in this game and it's
it's such a refreshing battle mechanic
yeah that's already layered on top of
this I this awesome idea of let's pit
pit nike Vikings nights and samurai
against each other and settle all those
classic playground debates like fun
concept really really cool gameplay that
I haven't really seen executed this this
precise
Lina game before uh looks gorgeous I'm
really really exciting one of my top
contenders of e3 this year you know what
it kind of reminds me of and it's kind
of in invoke in a minute to compare
everything to Dark Souls but I'm going
to compare it to Dark Souls it just it's
more tactical combat like the thing that
I interviewed Jason Vandenberg the
incredible creative director he I mean
basically he has a the voice and the
enthusiastic I've never quite better dev
like him he's so enthusiastic about his
game and you know he was saying that he
wants gamers to feel panicky they once
in the feel like they're in the here
battle and the only other game that I've
ever really felt like that was dark
souls and that's precisely why it's
because you have to it's very considered
and measured you have to think about
what the other ponent is doing specially
PvP Dave you're a big dark souls guy can
you see those comparisons definitely
when it comes to like the multiplayer
gameplay we've seen in in dog sauce is
very much reading your opponent fainting
attacks to try to stay mobile and we did
see that in the in the Grand like
samurai vs night's game play that I
think was maybe a games young yeah and I
can't see the parallels I think because
fora de will be more team-based it might
it'll either take away from that because
you'll have your buddies beside you or
it will add to even more because you're
being attacked by three samurai those
are three targets you've gotta win but
what's amazing about that game is that
you can win that fight if you're good
enough yep yeah I'm really looking
forward to seeing how like the three
kind of warrior castes differentiate
from each other because again that's
going to play into the balance the game
it's going to play it to reader your
opponent's if you're fighting a samurai
who's much faster than you and drew a
night who's a lot more encumbered and
currently dodge on the way but you can
block very well it's going to be like a
layered like battle mechanic from from
what like you feel free to tell me if
I'm wrong but from what I've seen of it
it looks like it's very easy to play but
very hard to master yeah and I think
that's exactly it and and to your point
about you know the different classes
across biking night and samurai keep is
a Viking night and zombie but it's not
Viking Titan samurai a DLC you'd write
the zombie class that would be
incredible vikings vs zombies would be
amazing but i believe as i understand it
there are also classes within
each of those different right right so
if you're biking you could be like a
berserker Viking who is just kind of
like stripping off all his armor and
going and hacking and slashing his way
through it so you know I and and I
samurais you know with their longer
katanas are going to be dealing more at
a distance versus those Vikings who are
up there in your face with the axes and
using kind of brute force to file your
way through so I but to your point yeah
it's one of those games that could you
get through probably the basic story
mode hacking your way through it and
slashing your way through it I believe
so no similar to you would like a
dynasty warriors it's kind of a parallel
that comes to mind but especially with
those PvP battles and even the ones here
on the show floor with people handling
the game for the first time you have to
know what you're doing because you know
clearly they know and so you having to
counter and Perry their moves and
predict where they're going next it's a
really exciting mechanic it takes one of
the most exciting elements of Dark Souls
and kind of makes it builds a full game
around it which is really cool what I
think is really interesting is they said
that in what class you pick is kind of
like a psychological read on you they
say that you know nights are all for
honor and what foreigner Vikings are
more you know don't really care party
party yeah yeah I'm samurai obviously
you know steadfast as lies and so my
question to you guys which class are you
making and I'm taking notes for this I
cambiado I've already got the band's I'm
halfway there biking yeah yeah yeah like
I like the kind of brute strength and
Berserker like intensity of a Viking and
like it's obviously not completely based
in reality yes I give you if you were to
pick those guys against each other I
think Vikings gonna win yeah right yeah
no care let me bring out my battle-ax a
hack my way you're gonna smash that
katana in half the night is gonna be too
slow Vikings for the win I think Vikings
are gonna win but as far as like
personality assessment BuzzFeed quiz you
know what you're awesome character you i
would say i have to be a knight yeah
yeah I mean yeah it's a safe choice it's
a standard choice but the ideas of
chivalry of honor you know of doing your
duty and working hard and like for the
kingdom
you know for the greater good I I
believe in that you know what this is a
very balanced balanced a couple of couch
enamorada I'm gonna go somewhere nice
okay even doing things methodically and
mastering them and that's just it just
seems nice also i'm not very strong but
i'm very quick right i tire easily
because i don't really work out but you
know quick I think summarize workout
Lucy yeah they do train nope not at all
no I just have a big razor blade and
hope for the best that's how I get
through my life they also showed up some
of the single-player campaign which is
really interesting to me because it's I
thought forcibly should be 3 campaign
speech fraction but it's not it's one
campaign and you play as a night than
you plays a Viking most samurai how do
you think that'll kind of work out like
I don't know I'm really curious about
that won't quite honestly I like in the
in the trailer that they show during the
conference they're like oh there was
some massive global upheaval and these
three you know classic you know here and
cultural heritage things got just like
pangaea reformed I just got the Navy a
hero management flick into a bow like
fight it's like great you you do you
Ubisoft you figure out the story that
you need to tell to make this happen I
appreciate it it's ridiculous but I love
it um I i have to say i'm curious you
know it seems like the big bad appears
to be like some dark souls ian kind of
like female Knight who's like
Machiavellian controlling this universe
I don't know I have no idea I was little
she wants a world devoid of trust us yes
she was a real God that they've been
fighting for a thousand years decided
it's like congratulations you did it
well done oh man but also I think my
favorite tidbit from this game is the
way that they came up with the the
fighting mechanic and it's that the
Jason Vandenberg just started to learn
German long sword fighting in his spare
time and decided to make a game out of
it so my question to you guys is out of
all your hobbies what could you make a
game out of oh I would make some boring
games right I mean making YouTube videos
for a living there are already plenty of
games online approximately although yeah
there's already like tube tycoon
youtubers life and all these games that
people are playing all this year I'm
like this is not worthy material guys
like let me tell you the day is spend
answering emails it's not that exciting
so I spend my time like painting
warhammer or drinking too much so like I
mean if you can buy those two game
you're gonna there like like you got a
little model in your bed drunk you're
like well like ten a hundred points for
that effort I was gonna say it sounds
like some of those old mario party mini
games where like everyone's partying and
then you're trying to like use the
jittery hand to try and like trace over
the lines like the inaccurate Wii Remote
like God and that's a Goomba there you
go I know some of your hobbies so I did
crochet so I basically do um yup she's
willing what crochet samee our approach
a simulator the one thing I will say
before we hop off a for honor though I'm
really interested in is I have this
theory that I've done a couple videos on
about the Ubisoft connected universe the
the ub verse where different easter eggs
kind of show that these games all share
one collected universe right there's you
know references to Assassin's can watch
dogs there's references to Assassin's
Creed in a far cry I'm very curious to
see if that carries through in in for
honor and and how that might tell might
add into the overarching story I asked
yes so you asked I asked him so there
was a first civilization right yeah and
then everything kind of broke down and I
said okay well we know that Assassin's
Creed had a first civilization is it the
same as in the same world and he just
went nope so foreigner is not connected
in any way apparently no I know I don't
really demonstrate I think I think
they're lying to you I hope so I want to
believe right I want to believe make it
happen I know they're building their own
Marvel like it's their Marvel coolant in
the connected universe I mean they
already have the Civil War right yeah
this is it this is their Civil War and
then yeah they have south park and
everything good extension of other end
you think like know we've had the
assassins creed movie we're getting a
watch last IV are we gonna have a full
honor the movie I would watch the hell
out just just like a hundred and thirty
minutes of Jews fired I think about
that's all I days basically 300 right
yes yeah samurais know
aids and vikings and thrown zombies the
plot is again third act they all unite
against zombies all right I think that
wraps it up pretty much with zeldron for
honor don't go anywhere because we are
going to be talking about we worked over
the new consoles sonio Scorpio NX please
dongho anyway come back to the game spot
stage here at e3 2016